[Music]
displaced from their homes inside Gaza
on this Wednesday night thousands flee
Northern Gaza on foot as pressure mounts
on Israel to stop killing civilians
there is something that is clearly wrong
an Arab Israeli man's remarkable story
helping Jews furious with Hamas look at
this it's not Islam his calls for peace
Healthcare overhaul in Alberta the
current system is one that is forgotten
who should be at the center of its
existence why the plan to dismantle the
AHS has some people worried I have
concerns and my colleagues have concerns
and there's a lot of
trepidation and honoring indigenous
veterans and they served with
distinction and then came back and were
met with the most atrocious inequities
shining a light on an overlooked
contribution to this country's history
global national with Donna freezen good
evening and thanks for joining us as
Israel's military tightens its strangle
hold on gaza's largest city there are
reports qter and Egypt are negotiating a
deal with Hamas to release up to 15
hostages in exchange for a 48h hour
pause in fighting Israel's prime
minister though said again tonight there
will be no ceasefire without the release
of the more than 200 hostages held by
Hamas in the heart of Gaza Palestinians
were fleeing on foot today 50,000 of
them Israel says Israel's military says
it kept that road open for 5 hours so
people could seek safety in the South
but it is not safe there international
pressure on Israel is intensifying
foreign ministers meeting at the G7
calling for a humanitarian pause and
saying a two-state solution is the only
path to a just and Lasting peace no one
got out of Gaza today that Rafa Crossing
to Egypt stayed closed our coverage
begins with Danielle Hamin and a warning
some of the details in her story are
disturbing the Gaza Skyline on day 33 of
this
conflict the Israeli Army has now
Advanced further into The Enclave than
in any previous war since its withdrawal
from the territory in
2005 and as the military campaign
intensifies Israel has given Palestinian
civilians a choice flee now or get
trapped in the north where violence has
and will continue to
escalate and so thousands again today
made their way South through a corridor
open for several hours Israel says
they'll be able to return but to what
and under whose authority Israel's
staunchest Ally has made its position
clear one uh Gaza cannot be uh continue
to be run by Hamas
um uh that simply invites a repetition
of October 7th uh and Gaza uses a place
from which to launch terrorist attacks
uh it's also clear that Israel cannot
occupy
Gaza Israel's long-term plans are vague
but for Palestinian civilians even in
the South where it's meant to be
safer the only goal now to
survive small ball IES wrapped in white
shroud and the unbearable sound of
apparent
wailing the UN says the worst conflicts
around the world can kill up to hundreds
of children maximum here it's already in
the thousands the number of civilians
that were killed with the military
operations there is something that is
clearly wrong Israel believes the
consequences of its War are Justified
its main objective now is to reach Hamas
headquarters which the IDF believes are
under the alifa hospital in central
Gaza the latest pictures out of there
show bulldozers being used to recover
the
bodies the Israeli military is closing
in and building up its
case Gaza claimed the Israeli defense
minister is the biggest Terror base ever
built by mankind but according to the UN
Human Rights Chief the actions of one
party do not absolve the actions of the
other party saying today that war crimes
have been committed by both Israel and
Hamas Donna Danielle hamam Jin in
Jerusalem thanks in Israel a funeral
took place today for a 20-year-old
Soldier staff sergeant yam glass was
only recently confirmed to have been
killed during during the October 7th
attack by Hamas she was among roughly
1,400 people killed that day Israel says
more than 340 of its soldiers have died
since its war on Hamas began last month
31 of them have been killed since Israel
expanded its ground operations inside
Gaza nearly two weeks ago Israel was
founded as a Homeland for the Jewish
people but a significant part of the
population has always been Arab known as
Arab Israelis or Palestinian Israelis
they are descendants of Palestinians who
did not flee and were not expelled
during the 1948 Arab Israeli War they
make up 21% of Israel's population most
are Muslim but some are Christian while
Israel says it grants them equal rights
many Arabs say they face structural
discrimination and hostile policies a
2021 report by the Israel democracy
Institute found significant social and
economic gaps between Jewish and Arab
citizens with poverty among Arabs more
than three times higher Rahat in
southern Israel is home home to roughly
880,000 Arab Israelis our Mike Armstrong
has a remarkable story tonight of one
man who lives
there it has the feel of organized chaos
Volunteers in a community center packing
boxes with food hundreds to help not
just the Muslims in Rahat but also the
Jews in towns and Villages around it
this is a time they say when it's more
important than ever to work together now
in the middle of the group a man who
says he has to be here has to be around
people not everyone knows him but when
they hear his story handshakes turn to
hugs Yu zedna lost a cousin killed in
the October 7th Hamas attacks and four
other members of his family were taken
hostage now both of those Fates could
have been
his this is video shot by zedna as he
drove into the October 7th attacks he
was driving a minius and was supposed to
pick up a group of Jewish young people
at the Nova Music
Festival zedna says when he heard there
was a rocket attack he went early by the
time he arrived it was a massacre he saw
gunmen mowing people down and Hamas
fighters in paragliders circling
overhead shooting anyone they could
through it he was able to find the group
he was supposed to meet and get all of
them
out Facebook one of the people he helped
save posted the story on Facebook and it
spread zedna says he got calls thanking
him from around the world he also got
one from Hamas a threat saying because
he's a Muslim who saved 30 Jews they're
going to kill him and his
family zedna says he's had trouble
understanding what happened that his
religion Islam isn't about slaughtering
people all the bedan tribes and all the
Arab Israelis he says are shocked look
at this it's not Islam it's a disbelief
shared by talum alawi there are multiple
Hamas videos that show one of his
friends being killed they take his watch
his money his phone and then he's
executed on the side of the road it's my
friend it's a good man Osama obasa it's
Arabic man Muslim man Alara says his
friend was Palestinian he gave to
Palestinian causes and supported gazin
what Hamas did he says doesn't make
sense but he's also having trouble with
what's going on in Gaza now it's
important he says that the Israeli
Defense Forces do everything they can
not to kill civilians right now he's not
sure they
are violence gives birth to more
violence he said says they have to fight
terrorists not
civilians now alawi says there are two
options for what comes out of this
either an even bigger war or like in
this room more cooperation and peace he
says he knows which one he's hoping for
Mike Armstrong Global News Rahat
Israel in Brazil police have arrested
two men who were reportedly plotting to
launch Terror attacks against the Jewish
Community Police suspect men have links
to the Lebanese militant group Hezbollah
and that their plans included targeting
synagogues Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin netanyahu's office says
Israel's spy agency mosad worked with
Brazilian Security Services and other
International agencies in making those
arrests Ukraine fears the world's
attention on Israel will come at its
expense though its ambition to join the
European Union got a boost today today
the commission
recommends that the council opens
accession
negotiations with Ukraine and with
Moldova the eu's executive body said
detailed negotiations should begin next
year the 27 EU leaders are due to decide
in mid December whether to accept that
recommendation Ukraine has wanted to
join the EU for over a decade President
Vladimir zalinski calls this an historic
step though it can take years to meet
the extensive legal and economic
criteria to join the EU is also wary of
taking in a country at War
in Panama a third week of protests over
a Canadian linked copper mine have
turned deadly disturbing video shows a
confrontation before two protesters were
shot they were blocking the panamic
highway when a driver pulled out a gun
he appears to try to dismantle the
roadblock then opens fire two of the
protesters died the suspect is a
77-year-old dual citizen of the US and
Panama there have been widespread
protests in Panama over for the
government's decision to Grant a 20-year
extension of Mining rights to the local
subsidiary of canada-based first Quantum
minerals the Alberta Government has
revealed plans to overhaul that
province's Health Care System Premier
Danielle Smith says Alberta Health
Services has lost its way and is too big
to meet the needs of patients so she
intends to dismantle it dividing it into
four parts the question is whether that
will result in improvements to Patient
Care Heather uck West explains
Dwight gillan's home has grown quiet now
that he's alone his wife of 53 years
lives in a long-term care facility in
another town I wanted to get her back
into Calgary and now I'm waiting like 6
to 8 months the lengthy weight just one
of a long list of problems plaguing
Alberta's Health System it's why the
premier says it's time for a change the
current Alberta Healthcare System is one
that is forgotten who should be at the
center of of its existence patients and
the healthc Care Experts who look after
them Healthcare was centralized under a
massive superboard Alberta Health
Services back in 2008 Ed stelck was the
premier I'm going to be very Frank the
decision making in this province in
terms of budgets
infrastructure and policy is made by
government it's made by elected
people and we drifted away from that the
new system would see Alberta's
government regain that control with
system delivery broken up into four
parts AHS will focus on acute care with
three additional bodies being created to
oversee Mental Health Services primary
care and long-term continuing care I
have concerns and my colleagues have
concerns and there's a lot of
trepidation the system's fragile right
now any change that you do can cause you
know uh disruption and sometimes even
now even small changes can cause chaos
the government says the restructuring is
not about privatization or cutting costs
but over the last few months Danielle
Smith's UCP government has made plenty
of waves it just seems that they want
more control over it to be able to
control what happens when and where it
happens and how it happens and again the
last time I checked the the government
isn't doctors The Province says it will
listen to healthcare workers and and
patience in engagement sessions over the
winter with plans to move ahead with the
first phase of changes as early as this
spring Heather URI West Global News
Calgary Maverick management has
confirmed the bus carrying the crew of
Canadian singer songwriter Shania Twain
was involved in a crash in Saskatchewan
it happened this morning near wolsley
that's about 100 kilometers east of
Regina Twain was not on board that bus
the local fire chief says 13 people were
freed from it and sent to hospital the
crew was on route to Saskatoon after a
show in Winnipeg last night coming up
what some state election victories could
mean for the 2024 US presidential
race in just one year the world will
find out who the next American president
will be and we got a bit of a hint this
week of what may motivate voters a
series of state level elections revealed
frustrations at Republican attempts to
criminalize abortion 2024 is expected to
be a rematch between Donald Trump and
Joe Biden Jackson prco looks at what
could shape that
race conservative Kentucky reelected a
Democrat as Governor a choice not to
move to the right or to the left but to
move forward for every single family
Republican dominated Ohio voted
overwhelmingly to protect abortion
access and in Virginia where where the
Republican governor campaigned on an
abortion ban the legislature flipped for
Democrats this was a big night for
Democrats they could hardly have done
better it's abortion it's abortion
rights the Republicans have taken the
unpopular side of the abortion rights
controversy it's the second election in
a row where the issue dominated the
voters said look the government should
not be telling a woman what to do with
her body one year out from the next
Presidential election it's not clear
Republicans can overcome that anger when
people see that they have lost something
they're more likely to translate that
into political action despite their wins
Democrats are hardly feeling confident
in a likely rematch between Joe Biden
and Donald Trump polls show Trump is
well ahead in almost every single
Battleground State the polls showing
that Biden is losing to Trump and all
those key states are a useful warning to
the White House some something they have
to worry about and correct over the next
year that's where abortion access May
once again become a central campaign
issue one proven to Trump voters views
of two unpopular presidential candidates
Jackson prosco Global News
Washington finding a place to live ahead
addressing Canada's growing problem of
[Music]
homelessness
as Colder Weather Creeps in Canada's
housing crisis is heating up a National
Conference in Halifax focused on ending
homelessness is looking at Solutions and
success stories as Heidi petruk explains
with more than a quarter of a million
Canadians experiencing homelessness this
year the challenge is
significant I uh walked up to and said
look this is yours that was the day
Melvin Ellsworth gave his tent away this
was home from the 1st of July
till the about the first week of October
he's one of the lucky ones offered a
room to rent by a stranger but there are
so many more without it's estimated up
to 300,000 Canadians have experienced
homelessness over the past year a count
in Vancouver found 4,800 people homeless
up 32% from 2020 in Toronto more than
10,000 people are homeless and there are
more than 4600 in Montreal and more than
1,000 in Halifax we need more housing a
100% figuring out how has brought 1,800
people working in homelessness to a
National Conference in Halifax Decades
of neglect Advocates say takes time to
reverse many agencies that work with
people who are homeless acknowledge
there won't be enough space for everyone
come this winter and they will just have
to work with those living in tents to
keep them alive we are seeing an
increase in encampments London Ontario
one city focusing on helping the
homeless make it through winter with the
City's director of housing stability
really wants long-term funding that
would be the one barrier we see is just
that you know anything three or four
years down the road it's really hard to
plan and and figure out funding
homelessness and housing policy is a bit
like the political equivalent of a high
school dance right cuz they got all
these people in the room they're staring
at their feet waiting for someone else
to make the first move the political
dance on display this week when some
provincial Premier criticized Ottawa for
failing to consult them on Fally funded
projects in their own backyards concerns
Sean Frasier dismissed there is no
reasonable excuse to slow down when we
actually have a program that is proving
it is working as the country tackles a
problem that's only worsened since the
pandemic we need to build more housing
and it and it straight up comes down to
the cost of housing a cost that has so
many Canadians paying the price this
winter Heidi pic Global News
Halifax one of the Canadian women
suspected of traveling to Syria to join
the so-called Islamic State appeared in
a BC courtroom yesterday 51-year-old
Kimberly pman was challenging a
counterterrorism peace bond that imposes
restrictions on her she's not facing any
criminal charges and claims she's
innocent Jeff stle explains her
case the so-called Islamic State
released this video back in 2018
highlighting the role of
women theba NBA was an all female Isis
Battalion the RCMP alleges its members
included this Canadian Kimberly pman now
living in BC's Fraser Valley Kimberly
anything you want to say pman who
appeared in court Tuesday isn't facing
any criminal charges and the RCMP
allegations have not been proven but
this 122 page police report just
unsealed and obtained by global news
outlines the rcmp's investigation based
on the allegations she did play um an
active role with Isis this National
Security law expert traveled to Syria
with global news in 2019 and interviewed
pman after her arrest I mean my think
he's a little bit unique she claimed she
was an innocent victim who realized her
mistak soon after arriving in Syria in
2015 I'd been trying to get out since
about maybe two weeks after I
arrived yeah yeah but the police report
says Pullman's own children described
her as a path logical
liar the report alleges pman was trained
to fight that she helped move weapons
and treated injured Isis Fighters there
is a really powerful stereotype about
women not being involved in violence and
political violence and to a certain
extent the women of the Islamic State
have benefited from that stereotype you
know we see far fewer charges for them
than we see for the men pman is one of
nine women Global Affairs helped
repatriate from Syria this this year
police say Pullman's daughter told them
my mom abandoned me to join a terrorist
organization we aren't sure if she
should really come back because she
might try to blow us all up pman was
released on a peace bond which includes
restrictions on driving travel and
internet use it expires after 8 months
Jeff simple global
news for decades they were left out of
Remembrance Day ceremonies next how
indigenous veterans are being honored
now
as we approach Remembrance Day we want
to shine a light on an often overlooked
part of Canada's history for decades
indigenous veterans weren't allowed to
participate in Remembrance Day
ceremonies as a group even though
they've been part of Canada's military
history for over 200 years after Decades
of being excluded they chose November
8th as Aboriginal Veterans Day Melissa
rigin on an idea that started in
Winnipeg and has spread across the
country
[Music]
the gift of song O Canada in a jibway to
honor indigenous Veterans as many as
12,000 have served in Canada's War
efforts first nation in with matey in
the first world war the second world war
the Korean War they fought they enlisted
at a higher ratio than any other diet
identifiable group in many are among
most decorated war heroes but they did
not return to a hero's welcome they
served with distinction and then came
back and were um met with the most
atrocious inequities they weren't even
allowed to lay wreaths at Remembrance
Day ceremonies until 1995 Canadian
public needs to know that the reason uh
that we have ad virginal Veterans Day on
uh on November the 8th is that until um
was established in
1994 by some indigenous veterans in
Manitoba because the Canadian Legion and
other organizations were not allowing
indigenous veterans to participate in
remembrance St Services what are we
working on times have changed Chief
Warrant Officer Carmen bear comes from a
long line of service people from the
MUSC First Nation it was explained to me
what they did the honor that they
brought to the uh First Nations which uh
basically inspired me to become who I am
today bear says the Canadian Armed
Forces have evolved for indigenous
Personnel he hopes to see more join the
ranks I would encourage it it has been a
great experience for myself working with
a a an incredible
Crosscut
of Heroes from Canada from every Walk of
Life coming together working together on
one mission one goal to move forward
ahead with each other is incredible
Melissa Ren Global News
Winnipeg on Saturday Global News will
have special coverage including a live
presentation of the Remembrance Day
service in Ottawa our coverage begins at
10:30 a.m. eastern on global and on all
our streaming platforms that is global
national for this Wednesday I'm Donna
freezen tonight's here Canada is the
veteran section of Riverside Memorial
Park Cemetery in Regina thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye